[Musique]
entretiens politiques avec nicolas de la
ville le maire de la verrière bonjour
bonjour alors la verrière pour situer
c'est une ville d'environ 7000 habitants
proche de l'encours du
mesnil-saint-denis de maurepas c'est une
ville qui est découpé en plusieurs
quartiers dont au quartier qu'on classe
généralement dans le quartier dit
difficile c'est de quartier du bois de
l'étang on va y revenir mais d'abord aux
couleurs voilà pour les soeurs voit la
politique de la ville
absolument mais je voudrais d'abord
qu'on revienne un peu sur cette élection
c'était la deuxième fois que vous vous
présentiez comme maire c'est une c'était
la verrière ses bastions communistes
avec le recul à quoi vous pensez vous
devez votre élection outre vos propres
qualités mais est ce qu'il y avait c'est
vrai qu'il y avait une des visions de
vos concurrents
mais ce qu'il y avait aussi peut-être la
volonté de tourner une page historique
qui était cette page du communisme
municipal
bah écoutez c'est vrai et qu'il ya
plusieurs raisons qui explique je pense
notre notre élection
je pense qu'il ya eu quand même un long
travail de fait sur la durée par notre
équipe
on était une équipe dans l'opposition et
c'est vrai que dans l'opposition pendant
six ans on a assisté à tous les conseils
municipaux
on s'est accroché on a proposé on a
alerté en tout cas on a on n'a pas
arrêté d'être présent et c'est ce long
travail qui fait que cela a porté ses
fruits
le jour de l'élection et c'était pas
évident notamment dans ce contexte de
confinement et de et de crise sanitaire
même dans l'opposition on a continué à
être présent avec toute mon équipe
peut-être comme vous dites une attente
très forte des habitants de d'efficacité
je pense qu'il voyait bien que la
verrière avait un potentiel
extraordinaire que la verrière avait
beaucoup de d'actions à mettre en place
et beaucoup d'habitants estimé
que l'équipe précédent l'équipe
municipale précédente n'était pas
suffisamment dynamiques n'était pas
suffisamment présente sur le terrain
n'était pas suffisamment impulsive pour
pousser ses projets sur l'éducation sur
la sécurité
et c'est vrai qu'il ya un moment donné
où les problèmes étaient trop visible et
il y avait trop d'impatience de la part
des habitants
voilà je pense que c'est quelques
raisons et puis une autre raison très
importante aussi patrice carmouze
c'est je pense que les habitants ils
veulent une équipe de compétences à une
équipe d'idéologues qui soit de gauche
de droite du centre ou apolitiques les
habitants ils veulent un maire des élus
qu'ils soient proches de leurs
préoccupations et qui résonne pas
uniquement dans des jeux politiciens
voilà on soit du parti communiste ou du
parti socialiste je pense que il y avait
ils ont pris conscience parce que cela
avait peu d'importance
il voulait un maire une équipe
municipale qui résonne un peu moins en
termes politiciens politiques
idéologiques mais qui raisonne en termes
de projets et donc on a réussi à avoir
effectivement des électeurs qui était
plutôt de sensibilité de gauche mais qui
se reconnaissaient dans notre projet sur
l'éducation sur la sécurité et qui est
un projet en fait de bon sens ce n'est
pas un projet de droite de gauche disent
quand c'est un projet de bon sens pour
améliorer la verrière est ce que si vous
après votre votre élection
et quel est le regard que vous portez
sur vos premiers pas de mer est ce qu'il
ya des choses qui vous ont surprises
dans l'exercice de cette fonction est
est ce que c'est une fonction qui rend
heureux mais écoutez moi ça me rend très
heureux très heureux parce que
humainement c'est très riche
c'est vrai que de devoir à l'état civil
un père de famille voilà venir pour
suite au décès de son enfant sa marque
profondément le maire que je suis
célébrer l'union de deux personnes lors
d'un mariage c'est des moments il
oubliable être sur le terrain à porter
d'engueulades comme on le dit souvent
c'est vrai que ça secoue
mais en même temps il ya beaucoup de
satisfaction de voir les choses avancer
on effectivement alertés quand ça va mal
mais il ya aussi des habitants qui une
fois que le problème est résolu nous le
font savoir et tout cela apporte
beaucoup de satisfaction humaine et je
trouve que voilà pour être heureux dans
ce mandat de maire il faut aimer les
gens et c'est vrai que c'est la voilà je
trouve la source de satisfaction
principale c'est de partager des projets
avec mon équipe
et puis de pousser ses projets avec les
habitants et et ça ça me rend
profondément heureux alors je parlais du
quartier de bois de l'étang que vous
disiez quartiers populaires quartiers de
la politique de la ville vous avez
décidé des déplacés des médiateurs et à
notre deux qui sont financés en grande
partie par l'état puis quatre autres je
crois que sont des vacataires
quel est leur rôle est alors visiblement
efficace puisque je les ai cru
comprendre que pour la depuis longtemps
dans la nuit du 31 décembre au 1er
janvier
il n'y a pas eu par exemple de deux
voitures brûlées est ce que c est ce que
c'est à eux qu'on doit ça et cette
initiative qu'on doit sa notamment bien
sûr c'était un de nos engagements de
campagne
c'était un dispositif sur lequel on
croyait beaucoup ça faisait quatre ans
que la municipalité précédente expliqué
qu'il n'y arrivait pas à mobiliser de
médiateur avec ce n'était pas de leur
faute que c'était de la faute de la
préfecture et c'est vrai que cette
situation elle était incompréhensible
dès notre arrivée on a consacré une
énergie folle à aller chercher ces
financements de l'état et on les a
obtenus donc on a effectivement deux
adultes heureux les financer en quasi
totalité par l'état qui sont donc des
agents de la ville et on a renforcé ses
agents
municipaux par une équipe de vacataires
qui sont des médiateurs expérimentés qui
ont essentiellement deux missions ce
sont des médiateurs qui marche sur deux
jambes
la première jambe elle est sociale pour
renouer le dialogue avec les jeunes pour
être à leur écoute pour faire passer les
bons messages pour faire pour vraiment
faire prendre conscience aux jeunes que
on peut être aller vers le pire ou vers
le meilleur est ces médiateurs qu'on a
sélectionnés rigoureusement ce sont des
parcours de réussite est donc ce sont
des jeunes qui vont vraiment essayé de
pousser nos jeunes vers le meilleur et
puis le deuxième jambe nos médiateurs
une jambe tranquillité publique pour
assurer je dirais la meilleure
tranquillité possible dans tous nos
cartes il pas seulement au bois de
l'étang également à orly parc et au
village et pour qu'on respecte le
voisinage pour que les halls d'immeubles
ne soit pas souhaité pour que les en
termes de motocross notamment sur les
rodéos les jeunes puissent prendre
conscience du danger de ce type de
pratiques
voilà faire passer les bons messages ce
sont essentiellement des médiateurs
issus de la ville issus de nos quartiers
qui sont respectées par les jeunes et
avec qui les jeunes ont eu un dialogue
peut-être plus plus libérée que la
police dont ce n'est pas la principale
mission que d'aller dialoguer avec les
jeunes donc ils ont vraiment c2c ces
deux missions et c'est vrai que pendant
le réveillon de la saint sylvestre
ça s'est relativement bien passée
c'était un peu historique
grâce à ces médiateurs qui étaient
déployés sur nos terrains pour être
vraiment en constant dialogue avec les
jeunes et leur faire prendre conscience
que faire rouler des poubelles faire
brûler des voitures
voilà ça dégrader notre commune et que
c'était nos familles qui allez en payer
les pots cassés alors valérie pécresse
la présidente de la région ile de france
dit que ça ça à l'absence d'une vraie
politique de rénovation urbaine parfois
il faut savoir détruire
des ghettos quand il existait ce que la
verrière est concerné par ce propos ou
pas bah écoutez c'est un sujet très
important sur la verrière effectivement
la rénovation de nos quartiers on a déjà
engagé une rénovation à venir du parc
avec plusieurs décisions qui ont été
prises on est revenu sur cette maison de
quartier qui était prévu par l'ancienne
municipalité dans un espace qui
n'étaient pas optimales les habitants
craignent et des nuisances notamment
sonores en terme de stationnement donc
on a mis fin à cette construction de
maisons de quartier à cet emplacement là
qu'on trouve un nouvel emplacement et on
est en train de lancer en lien avec le
département
toute une réflexion sur sur orly parc
pour que dans le mandat on est des
nouvelles aires de jeux des nouveaux
jardins partagés également des espaces
de vie pour nos habitants donc toute
cette réflexion à l'engager pour le
mandat sur orly parc sur le bois de
l'étang
on est en train d'étudier toutes les
pistes possibles sans tabou pour qu'on
est les meilleurs investissements
possibles dans d'autres quartiers du
boîtier temps puisqu'on peut pas se
permettre de laisser le bois de l'étang
à l'abandon tel qu'il l'avait été depuis
trop d'années et donc il faut qu'on
réfléchisse collectivement sur une
nouvelle entrée de ville pour que on est
d'entrée de ville à la verrière et
auprès de l'étang qui soit digne de ce
nom
toute une réflexion sur les équipements
publics notamment une école qui puisse
être la plus innovante et la la plus
accueillante possible sur une maison de
quartier qui aujourd'hui très obsolète
sur une offre commerciale qui doit à mon
sens être plus attractive on a
heureusement des commerçants qui
s'implanteront lehrer on est très fiers
de les avoir mais il faut que cette zone
commerciale puissent aussi avoir
peut-être une zone de chalandise plus
large en lien avec la zone d'activités
de trappes elancourt bref tous ces
sujets là il faut qu'on les mette sur la
table
sans tabou pour qu'on ait le maximum
d'investissements possibles et c'est le
sujet je pense c'est que aujourd'hui les
partenaires sont prêts à nous suivre
mais pas n'importe quelle condition et
donc il faut que on les mobilise pour
avoir de l'argent pour pouvoir apporter
des solutions concrètes aux habitants et
donc tout tout tout ce sujet là bien
évidemment qu'on y réfléchit et on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler dans les mois
qui viennent les médiateurs la
rénovation urbaine
est ce que tout ça ça appartient
finalement l'une de ce kit est votre
priorité aux priorités pendant la
campagne c'était l'éducation exactement
c'est un autre grand thème sur lequel on
s'est investi beaucoup depuis le début
de notre mandat
dès notre arrivée aux responsabilités
on a consacré des moyens pour mettre une
atsem par classe pour vraiment
accueillir au maximum nos petits enfants
on a mis le paquet sur la modernisation
de toutes nos écoles
donc on a aujourd'hui un ternie par
classe un tableau numérique interactif
on a également des tablettes tactiles
qui sont déployés dans nos écoles on a
également des petits robots pour former
nos jeunes à la programmation
informatique qui arrive on va également
miser sur les espaces numériques de
travail et on vient de lancer les le
soutien scolaire en ligne gratuit pour
tous les enfants du cp au cm2 pour
vraiment misé sur l'égalité des chances
à l'école
quel que soit notre origine sociale on
aura accès à cette plateforme de cours
et d'exercices en ligne qui ont été
faits par des enseignants de l'éducation
nationale pour vraiment qu'on améliore
les résultats scolaires de nos enfants
parce que la réussite
elle n'est pas réservé qu'à quelques
enfants elle doit être le le plus
élargie possible le plus accessible
possible et ça c'est notre grand combat
c'est la réussite de tous nos enfants
quel que soit son origine sociale
merci beaucoup nicolas dainville et à
très vite pour parler évidemment de la
verrière
et avec gonflables
[Musique]